we've already seen that the fraction two
fists or fraction like the fraction two
fists can be literally represented as
two times 1/5 2 times 1/5 which is the
same thing which is equal to literally
having two 1/5 so 1/5 plus 1/5 and if we
wanted to visualize it let me make a
hole here and divide it into five equal
sections and so this represents two of
those fifths this is the first of the
fifths and then this is the second of
the fifths literally 2/5 2/5 2/5 now
let's think about something a little bit
more interesting
what would 3 times 2/5 represent 3 times
2/5 and I encourage you to pause this
video and based on what we just did here
think about what you think this would be
equivalent to well we just saw that 2/5
would be the same thing as so let me
just rewrite this as instead of 3 times
2/5 written like this let me write 2/5
like that so this is the same thing as 3
times 2 times 1/5 3 times 2 times 1/5
times 1/5 and multiplication we could
multiply the 2 times the 1/5 first and
then multiply by the 3 or we could
multiply the 3 times the 2 first and
then multiply by the 1/5 so you could
view this literally as being equal to 3
times 2 is of course 6 so this is the
same thing as 6 times once 6 times 1/5 6
times 1/5 and if we were to try to
visualize that again so that's a whole
that's another whole each of those holes
have been divided into five equal
sections and so we're going to color in
we're going to color in six of them so
that's the first fifth second fifth
third fifth fourth fifth fifth fifth and
that gets us to a hole and then we have
Fifth's just like that so literally 3
times 2/5 can be viewed as six fifths
and of course six times 1/5 or six
fifths can be written as so this is
equal to literally six let me do the
same color six fifths
six over six over five now you might
have said well what if we instead of
viewing two fifths says this as we just
did in this example we view 2/5 as 1/5
plus 1/5 what would happen then well
let's try it out
so 3 times 2/5 I'll rewrite it 3 times
2/5 2 over 5 2/5 is the same thing as 3
times 3 times 1/5 plus 1/5 2/5 is the
same thing as 1/5 plus 1/5 so 3 times
1/5 plus 1/5 which would be equal to
well I just have to have literally 3 of
these added together so it's going to be
1/5 plus 1/5 plus 1/5 plus 1/5 plus I
think you get the idea here plus 1/5
plus 1/5 well what's this going to be
well we literally have 6 fifths here we
could ignore the parentheses and just
add all these together we once again
have 1 2 3 4 5 6 fifths so once again
this is equal to 6/5
so hopefully this shows that when you
multiply that 2/5 we saw already
represents 2 1/5
we already saw that or 2 times 1/5 and 3
times 2/5 is literally the same thing as
3 times 2 times 1/5 or in this case that
would be 6 fifths